you know if you look at classic hero
mythology which we're going to do in
great detail what you see is that the
typical myth of it of humanity is we
live in a place we'll say we have to
live in a place and the place is doing
quite nicely thank you very much like
The Hobbit Singh and Frodo right the
first one the Lord does the what was it
called the harlot yeah yeah The Hobbit
okay so you got a little Shire there
right it's all peaceful it's one of
these little people who are a little on
the arrogant side they're kind of dopey
they have no idea what the hell is going
on in the outside world
but they say that's okay they think you
know just you know peculiar people are
concerned about that sort of thing they
got their little tap and paradise going
they live a long time they eat a lot you
know they party a lot unbeknownst to
them which is very interesting feature
of the story the only reason they have
any peace at all is because they are
descendants of old kings continually
patrolling the borders right those are
the Striders Aragorn
he's a member of the race of old kings
who patrols the border well those are
those are ancestral figures it's like
you can all sit here your little happy
paradise but the only reason you can do
it is because the sons of great kings
have put borders around your kingdom and
you can think it's funny because in the
harvest that harvest basically despised
strider you like you're very very
suspicious of it he's kind of dirty and
dusty and he looks like he's being
banged around all over the world he's
sort of like a trap it's like they don't
know he's the son of a great king good
thing for them that he is however okay
so then you've got the little Shire and
what happens evil things are stirring
and what is it well fundamentally it's a
great dragon well that's a snake except
it's like met a snake you know it's it's
its snake with fire and you can be sure
that fire was not only one of our
greatest allies but one of our greatest
enemies especially when we lived on the
belt in Africa because that thing would
burn now and then you know and so get
the hell away from that and on well so
anyways so one Hobbit who's woken up by
a wizard
right the wizard is a symbol of the self
from the Union perspective so there's
one Hobbit who's a little bit more
creative and exploratory than the rest
and everybody has a lot of respect for
him but they think he's pretty damn
peculiar he decides that he's going to
under the tutelage of the wizard he's
going to go check out this dragon so he
leaves the borders and he goes out into
the unknown and then the rest of it is
an adventure and one of the things
that's very interesting again from a
union perspective is that what is the
Hobbit has to become in order to conquer
the dragon a feast now that's pretty
weird eh because you think hey man this
guy's out to be a hero so it should be a
hero like no he turns into a thief why
well it's because if you're going to
conquer a dragon you better be a hell of
a lot tougher than you are naive and so
partly what happens is that for The
Hobbit to muster up the forces that are
necessary for him to confront something
that is that fundamental he has to
transcend his coward what would you call
it the the cowardice that he describes
as morality
okay so Nietzsche for example each is
often viewed as a critic critic of
morality it's like that's not true what
because Nietzsche identifies morality
with cowardice but that's not what he
does what Nietzsche says is this if
you're too afraid to do something so you
won't do it then you'll say that the
reason that you don't do it is because
your moral that's not the reason the
reason is you're too damn afraid to do
it you might want to but you're too
afraid
that doesn't make you moral so what
happens to the harvest for examples once
he gets outside the kingdom he has to
develop a whole array of potentials that
he never developed before because they
were either not necessary in his
civilized place or because they were
forbidden as immoral by the cultural
situation that he grew up in so